[Musique]
les nominés dans la catégorie révélation
interprète voka de l'année sont je
m'appelle kevin crull j'ai 25 ans je
suis né en martinique
j'étais toute mon enfance au morne-rouge
et à partir de 18 ans j'ai décidé de
partir à paris pour poursuivre mes rêves
dans la musique et ensuite partir à
londres pour justement nous confronter à
d'autres influences artistiques
[Musique]
oc
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé la musique à l'âge de 12
ans justement au travers d'une comédie
musicale qui dénonce l enfance
maltraitée
et du coup j'ai pas vraiment commencé
avec l'opéra mais vraiment la petite
musique beaucoup plus lyrique et ce
n'est qu'il ya trois ans que j'ai
découvert cette voix de contre-ténor
voix de contre-ténor c'est une voix
justement d'opéra pas seulement mais
surtout et c'est une voix qui justement
travaille beaucoup dans l'aigu salut je
m'appelle au 1000 m
j'ai 20 ans originaire de la martinique
[Musique]
quand j'étais plus jeune quand j'ai
commencé à les former chanson j'ai pris
20 en anglais puisque je voulais être
une star mon modèle c'est très cher et
je me voyais faire des grosses dates
dans des gros stades en amérique dans le
monde et tout est en fait plus j'avance
plus je me dis que la martinique c'est
chez moi j'ai envie aussi de de
conquérir le public m'a enseigné que le
public antillais le public caribéen pas
seulement les antilles françaises mais
les antilles les îles anglophones
[Musique]
un souper accordé moins intimes
e
et
un souper tendait encore sentiments
[Musique]
salut c'est david obadia je suis artiste
auteur compositeur interprète
martiniquais
moment
[Musique]
je fais un style musical que je nomme
groove afro caribéens qui est un mélange
de jazz blues soul hip hop avec des
rythmes comme le chouval bwa le ti bwa
des rythmes latins du zouk également
il